all right so welcome everyone
to the workshop and uh as hugo mentioned
one of the main themes of this workshop
is the recent
progress and obfuscation so the purpose
of
the talk that i'm about to give is to
sort of bring everyone up to speed uh on
uh the constructions of obfuscation
which will be assumed in many of the uh
talks that we'll see later on in the
in the program and we'll see many
interesting
uh many interesting talks
um about obfuscation covering
essentially all angles of this of the
subject
so uh before we talk about the upcoming
talks
let's think for a moment what is
obfuscation
so uh suppose that you want to keep a
secret and i apologize for those of you
who are here at the boot camp this is
sort of a compressed version of my boot
camp
talk but i see lots of new faces in the
audience and i hope that you will
appreciate this so suppose you want to
keep a secret
and you want to keep the secret from an
adversary
but unfortunately for you the adversary
captures your entire brain okay
and in fact it takes your entire brain
and reads and tampers with the activity
of
every neuron in your brain
while you are thinking about the secret
that you want to keep from the adversary
so this is a very unfortunate scenario
one that
thankfully remains science fiction when
it applies
to humans but if we think about it the
exact computer science analog of the
scenario
happens all the time right the computer
science analog of this
is that we have a computer program which
is kind of like this brain right the
input output behavior
is exactly described by this computer
program and a computer program
in general in many cases is completely
captured by an adversary right the
adversary sees exactly
what the computer program does it sees
the entire listing of it
and the question we're asking is is it
possible
to keep a secret within a computer
program
even if the adversary captures the
entire program in its entirety
right and i want to stress that in this
situation
we have no trusted hardware no
interaction between parties
right just an ordinary program
with ordinary inputs and outputs no
encrypted inputs encrypted outputs
nothing like that just an ordinary
program
okay and all this running on again an
ordinary single computer
everything about the computer is public
everything but the initial state of the
computer is public
the adversary knows everything about
this right
before we continue let's think about how
this relates to
other concepts in cryptography
especially secure multi-party
computations will be another major theme
that we'll see many talks about in this
workshop
this is a you know one of our favorite
areas
to study and now usually when we talk
about secure multi-party computation
we think of it in terms of many
different parties that are talking to
each other
but i want to think about it a little
bit differently let's think about it in
terms of our giant brain here
we can think of secure multi-party
computation as taking our brain right
this computation that's taking place
with inputs and outputs and subdividing
it into little parts of this brain
right and in secure multiparty
computation
what we ask is even if the adversary can
tamper with and read some of these
subdivisions or in the most
aggressive case all but one of these
subdivisions
it should still be the case that a
secret is kept from the adversary
but again insecure multi-party
computation and this is really the key
difference with obfuscation
there's always at least one honest party
right one party that is completely
blocked and opaque
with respect to the adversary and once
we have this idea that there is a
part of the computation that's blocked
it leads to the natural
solution concept that we've studied for
many decades now
which is kind of to spread out the
computation using secret sharing or
garbling
and in this way make it so that as long
as the adversary misses some
part of the computation then he misses
all the essential features of it
right um and this is really
the the main difference as i mentioned
all these previous concepts
required that some part of the
computation be completely hidden from
the adversary
whereas in obfuscation no part of the
computation is hidden from the adversary
okay all right so
that's the vague notion of obfuscation
we want to drill in here and think about
specific definitions that we want to
achieve
now throughout this workshop we'll
actually see
many different definitions and uh there
have been many many different
definitions that have been studied
for obfuscation in particular stefano
omkand rachel and manoj later in the
workshop will all give talks
that discuss different kinds of
definitions of obfuscation
but today i want to focus just on the
most used
definition which is the notion of
indistinguishability
obfuscation okay so what is an
indistinguishability obfuscator
it's a probabilistic polynomial time
algorithm
subject to a few constraints first we
just have some basic
you know bookkeeping constraints okay so
the first constraint
is that when i obfuscate a program it
should preserve the input output
behavior it shouldn't change the input
output behavior
okay and it should at most cause a
polynomial slowdown where a theoretician
so just a polynomial slowdown is enough
for us
okay but then when it comes to security
what this definition asks for is the
following
if i have two programs p0 and p1
that are actually functionally
equivalent that is they have the same
input output behavior and the same size
then no adversary should be able to
distinguish
between the obfuscation of p0 and the
obfuscation of p1
okay and i put p0 and p1 here in
parentheses these to emphasize the fact
that even if the adversary is told
what the two programs were to begin with
even then you shouldn't be able to tell
whether
the obfuscation came from p0 or from p1
okay
i also want to stress that on the other
hand the obfuscator itself
only sees a single program it does not
know that there is some p0
and that's very important um both in
making security meaningful
as well as applying this notion
okay another way to think about this
notion of indistinguishability
obfuscation
is uh to think of it as a pseudo
canonicalizer
okay what i mean by that is that an
obfuscation of some program according to
this definition
is indistinguishable from and therefore
reveals no more than a canonical form of
the program
if one exists okay and
um this is sort of technically what is
going on here
right it's the fact that you can't
distinguish between different
representations in other words you've
got
sort of a pseudo canonical form of the
program
okay now um this definition
uh was proposed back in uh
over a decade ago um and there are no
impossible results known for this in the
standard model
that's good but it was an open problem
to construct it for a long time
and the first uh suggestion the first
candidate construction
was given a couple of years ago and
it's turned out to be surprisingly
useful after that
there's been a really a number of works
that have taken
this indistinguishability based
definition and leveraged it to actually
hide all kinds of interesting secrets
within programs
okay it kind of confirms our general
sense in cryptography that
you know simulation based definitions
give very strong and you know easy to
understand guarantees
but somehow these indistinguishability
the base definitions trying to be much
more versatile than they first seem
and this is definitely the case here as
well all right so
how is it useful let me give you just
one example
and i'm going to purposefully give you
an example that's simple so i can
explain in one slide
but more importantly it's the type of
application that we usually don't think
of as being in scope
for cryptography and that's one of the
things that's so exciting about
obfuscation is that it
takes things that seem to be out of
scope for cryptography and brings them
into the scope of cryptography
so what's the problem it's a problem
called crippleware
suppose that um i have you know
spent hours and hours and hours maybe
months years
developing some very powerful piece of
software okay
and this powerful software mixes with
powerful secrets to perform its input
output behavior okay and i want to sell
the software to you
but before you buy the soccer software
for me you want to be able to test it
out
right so what i want to do is give you
some sort of crippled demonstration
version
of this problem of this software right
now ideally what should i do i should
think about you know what features i can
safely reveal to you
redesign from scratch some computer
program so to make sure there are no
secrets within it no secrets that i'm
not willing to give out
right you know spend hours and months
potentially making the software and then
give it to somebody as a demo software
right now
this doesn't tend to happen right even
in real life what often happens is that
you know people just take their powerful
software and just edit the user
interface or some interface
aspect of it right to just [ __ ] that
but leave everything else the same
and it's a fun thing that hackers do to
go in and uh you know
hack this uh interface uh uh back to its
powerful form
right or to hack out the secrets that
are that are that are built into the
software
right now note that
the user the the input output behavior
of these two programs
are identical right all you in order to
change the input output behavior you
just need to
change the interface right so
given that obfuscation gives us a way to
solve this problem it allows us to do
this
in a secure manner why is that because
again these programs are functionally
equivalent
i can just obfuscate them using an
indistinguishability obfuscator
and by the guarantee of
indistinguishability obfuscation
we know that these two programs are
indistinguishable from each other
right and that means that it's safe for
us to release this obfuscated version of
the program
because we know that if an adversary
was somehow able to extract some secret
from this from the obfuscated version
then by indistinguishability he can also
extract that secret
from this version but this version has
no secrets to extract
right therefore it's impossible and
therefore we have
uh security you're assuming that
the in in the last
software the hacking doesn't happen
by formal input output like if i provide
that
well he'll form the input to your
program then something like a stack
overflow happens
right what i'm assuming here is that
these two programs before the
obfuscation
are equivalent and that's of course a
critical
that's why you know there are no free
lunches you know obfuscation does not
solve all problems
but it does bring into scope things that
usually we didn't think of being in
scope for cryptography
yes so we are assuming that this one if
you built it from scratch you would only
accept those inputs
right you wouldn't allow yeah right
right exactly and and and that's the way
this would work this idea
is just one little idea about how we can
use indistinguishability obfuscation
and there are many many many many many
many uses of institutionality
obfuscation in fact during the workshop
um we're going to see many such cases
today brent and prevention will talk
about it
on wednesday stefano thursday rachel
justin divya and eloni
will give us applications of i o and on
friday omer
planet will give us some some
applications of i o and there are many
many
applications that are known by now we
could have filled the entire workshop
with just
applications of of indistinguishability
obfuscation there's been so much work in
this area
and that's what makes it so exciting
right there that it's so useful it you
can do so much with it
okay so you're gonna see all of these
uses
so what i would like to do today is to
give you some
um more some some sort of grounding in
terms of why we should believe
that this object exists right how do we
construct it
and how do we show that it's secure okay
so before i do that just at a very high
conceptual level
let me tell you what the main idea is as
i see it
okay the main idea is something that
i'll call structured noise
the idea is that we take the program
components
we want to obfuscate and somehow add
noise to them
okay but this is special noise this is
not just random noise
this is noise subject to this remarkable
constraint
that if you combine these program
components exactly the way you're
supposed to
that is you run the program as specified
then this structured noise will somehow
magically cancel out at the last
possible moment at the last minute
the noise will go away and you will see
the output
okay on the other hand if the adversary
tries
anything else any other way of combining
components
modifying them doing anything else then
somehow that noise will survive
and hide the essence of whatever is
going on inside that computation
okay that's the idea that's what we want
to implement okay
so let me now jump just directly to how
this works
and we're going to start with
obfuscating matrix branching programs
and so let me just tell you what
what algebraic framework we're going to
be working in here
it's the multilinear map framework
and you will hear more about this uh in
the very next talk
so uh eric and mehdi will give a joint
presentation
uh that will go into the details of of
of the latest and greatest
uh multilinear map scheme uh the one
that seems to resist
as many attacks as possible and they
themselves are
going to be built using this idea of
structured noise okay so i'm not going
to go into the details of it but you'll
find out in the very next talk
okay but what is the overall structure
what is the idea here
the idea of multi-linear maps
is to work in a setting where you can do
various algebraic manipulations
but there are certain limits to what you
can do okay
and what are those okay first of all
what's the setting here
uh first there will be a certain upper
bound k
that's established a certain limit okay
and you have
levels one two three up to k
and for each such level there is
this object g sub i and g sub i is just
a copy
of the integer's modulo n for some large
random integer n okay and this n integer
n may have special forms we'll get to
that later
okay now what are you allowed to do
with these uh these rings gi
well you can add and when you add you
have to stay
within a certain ring okay so if you are
in gi
you can add another element that's
encoded in gi and get another encoding
of an element
in gi okay you can also multiply
across the levels so you can multiply
an encoding in gi and encoding in gj
and wind up in gi plus j
with an encoding again in gi plus j but
this is allowed
only if i plus j is at most k okay
if it goes beyond that then you're not
allowed to do these kind of
multiplications
and that's critical okay and then
finally
if you get an encoding at the very top
level at gk
then you can proceed to a zero test
and the zero test will answer actually
yes or no it will tell you whether or
not you have managed to construct
an encoding of the zero element and i
want to stress that only the zero test
procedure here actually yields unencoded
information
right all of the other things here are
kind of like fully morphic encryption
right they just
you take an encryption you get an
encryption but zero test actually
tells you do you have here an actual
encoding of zero or not
okay and this is really really critical
to us
okay and
in this sort of framework this algebraic
framework will eventually state some
computational hardness assumptions
just like we have hardness and
assumptions assumptions over
ddh groups or over bilinear
maps we're going to have
assumptions in this framework all right
um but not yet okay first i just want to
give you some ideas about how to
construct obfuscation
all right so um we start
with a program that's represented as a
matrix branching program
okay let me tell you a little bit about
what that is
so such a matrix branching program
consists of two k
invertible matrices and it's not a
coincidence that we're
using the letter k here and
the input length is fixed in this
example here i have n equals three
there are just three input bits and they
correspond to the colors blue
red and green okay and these matrices
come in pairs
and as you might imagine we use the bits
to select
one of these two matrices okay so to
evaluate such a program on an input x
all we do is take the input for example
1 0 0 would select these matrices
and just multiply them out just multiply
them in order okay
and that's the output so the output is
just the matrix product of all of these
matrices okay
and that's our notion of a program the
reason why we care about these programs
is because
barrington showed an accelerated result
that
all log depth circuits all nc1 circuits
have polynomial size matrix programs
and something that i want to tell you
about is that it turns out that all you
need to do is go to nc1
with the current research that we've
already done in our community
on foliomorphic encryption assuming
something like lwe
you can take an obfuscation that works
for nc1 circuits and bootstrap all the
way up
to an arbitrary circuit okay so what we
need to do now
is figure out how to obfuscate a program
that looks like this this sort of matrix
branching program okay
so um so let's make some progress
towards that
the first step is we apply a
randomization technique that's actually
due to killian and is
celebrated uh work on
uh building secure competition protocols
from oblivious transfer
so what does kilian do uh what killing
suggests for us to do
stated in our language here is we take
uh
random square matrices random invertible
matrices
r1 up to rk minus one okay
and uh just pick them at random over zn
i set r0 and rk to be the identity
matrix just to make things
work here okay and then what we can do
is we can take each of these matrices
and left multiply
by ri minus 1 and right multiply by ri
inverse right and this is really nice
right because this preserves the
iterated product
right because these are matrices exactly
cancel out right
and the other nice thing is it has this
sort of structured noise
flavor to it right it's only at the very
last
second right at the very last
multiplication that that final r
will go away and we'll make crucial use
of that um
in in our construction and proof okay
so we've got these uh m tildes now
okay and another really nice thing that
we'll make use of
is something else that killian showed he
showed that if you have a
specific x again think about 1 0 0 here
right then it is possible to simulate
the joint distribution of all of these
matrices
for that one particular input from just
the final product of all these matrices
in other words the output of this
program okay
and this may seem a little magical to
you if you haven't seen it before but
it's actually
extremely simple and it's sort of an
exercise for an undergrad
in a linear algebra course and i won't
tell you how to do it but
i encourage you who don't know to try
for yourselves and you can see how to
prove it
it's a very simple simple but very
powerful idea okay
all right so we've now taken our
matrices and randomized them in this way
okay that's sort of step one now what
are we going to do
we're going to take these matrices and
encode them
using our multilinear map right so
that's another nice thing the way that
we've set up our multilinear map
you know allows for multi-linear
operations
and sort of the prototypical
multi-linear operation is iterated
matrix product right iterated matrix
product
is linear in each individual matrix
right
so if we encode every entry of each of
these matrices at level 1
once we do the iterated product we'll
wind up with a product at level k
where we can then do zero testing and it
turns out that
that's sufficient these pro these final
products will always have a zero in it
that you can test for
okay um so that's great
it turns out that we're getting now very
close
actually to a plausible obfuscation
scheme
but there's one critical attack that
remains
there's one intuitively
and that is the input mixing attack
so let me describe that to you suppose
that i am
an adversary and i'm mostly nice
so i mostly do what i'm supposed to be
doing i start with
this matrix over here and i multiply it
with this matrix
multiplied by this matrix exactly the
way i'm supposed to
note now that i am committed to my input
right 1 0
0 and i'm supposed to multiply
with this matrix but nothing is forcing
me to do that
right i could multiply with this matrix
instead
and i can start to mix up these matrices
in a way that they're not supposed to be
mixed up
right and it turns out
that it's a really interesting question
actually to understand
how much information can be leaked in
these kinds of uh
with these kinds of attacks we don't
know how to bound it
and there are certainly examples where
these kinds of attacks do leak critical
information
so this is a real problem that
we really need to solve okay
this brings us to the question of how to
solve it
here i'm going to be a little bit fuzzy
i'm not going to give you a complete
answer but i'll
i'll hint to it a little bit later so
again remember what's the problem the
problem is that
the atmosphere could start with this
matrix but then later when he hits
another matrix that also corresponds to
this input
he can pick the wrong matrix right so we
have to focus
in on the matrices that correspond to a
single input right
and what do we want we want to force
good behavior
on the adversary right so
what does that mean what that means is
that we want it to be the case
that if the adversary starts with this
matrix
then he has no option he has to pick
this matrix and then pick this matrix he
can't
mix and match these things so we
illustrate this through these sort of
puzzle pieces
that you know i want this matrix to
somehow be encoded with respect to this
puzzle piece
so the only way i can kind of cover my
rectangle
is by putting these pieces together in
this way
whereas the puzzle pieces that i have
for the other matrices
go in the other direction right and the
only way to put them together
is in the other way okay um
this is obviously not a very technical
uh description of our solution to the
problem
um but there are actually many ways to
solve it one of the most
sort of popular ways now is through this
idea of a straddling set
um but uh this is a problem that we do
have to solve
um i
again i'm sorry i won't tell you more
about it because i just don't know i
don't have enough time to uh
to go into it uh but uh
but i will come back to this later the
critical point here is that this is a
problem that we do have to solve we do
have to think about
technical ways to prevent the adversary
from mixing up these sort of matrices
okay all right those are the basic those
are basically the main ideas
okay that are required to build an
obfuscation scheme
using uh multi-linear maps and these
using these matrix branching programs
okay
um we can if i you know if i could have
given a slightly different talk where i
would have been able to just
give you a scheme that we don't know how
to break okay but we're a little bit
further along in our research now
um so i'll actually sketch to you a way
that we can build a type of
indistinguishability obfuscator
for which we can actually prove security
based on a natural
concrete conjecture okay and
um uh and and let's think about
uh and now what do i mean by a natural
concrete
conjecture i mean an assumption right
the i promised you anyway from the
beginning that i would give you some
sort of assumptions
over this multilingual framework so let
me talk first about
what is the actual assumption what are
we going to assume from which we'll be
able to get obfuscation
okay so
i'll warm up with us with sort of a
special case
okay this is may seem like a completely
trivial case but let's just think about
it
suppose actually k equals one if k
equals one you have no multilinear you
have no actual multiplication that
you're allowed to do
you can just add things right this is
sort of a very
typical situation for us in crypto um
but the one little bit of a of an issue
that will come up more later
is that our n will be a composite number
it'll have two prime factors
okay and i'm going to give them names so
we're going to have one
special prime factor that i'm going to
call c
and one distinguished prime factor that
i'm going to call a1
okay and
when i think about the the plain text
when i think about just a number
right in zn i'm going to represent and
use the chinese remainder here right so
i'll look at it
the mod c component and the mod a1
component okay
we'll call this the c component and the
a1 component right
now um we have to give some things to
the adversary to state an assumption
so what we're going to do is we're going
to give the adversary a level 1 encoding
of several things first we're going to
give a
random generator of each prime subgroup
except for c well there's only one in
this case
just start distinguishing prime factor
a1 so in other words i give him
the encoding of something that looks
like zero comma r1
okay remember this is a multi-linear
encoding right so it's not i'm not
actually giving him
the number that is zero comma r1 i'm
giving him an encoding of it
which should intuitively hide the fact
that it has this form
okay furthermore i also give him another
element which i'm going to call h1 which
for right now just looks like the
opposite it's zero
in the a1 component but it has something
in the c component
okay and now
what i assume is hard in this assumption
is that it's hard for the adversary to
distinguish
between just a completely
the encoding of a completely random
element
versus the encoding of an element that
is zero in the c
subgroup but random in the a1 subgroup
okay so again intuitively what we're
doing here is we're assuming
that the encoding hides the
structure with respect to the primes
here right
this is essentially the subgroup
decision assumption without the pairings
okay so this is just the idea for those
of you who are familiar with the
subgroup decision assumption
this is very similar but even without
any pairing being there
okay and indeed in the next talk when we
see
an example when we see constructions of
multi-linear maps
they will support these kinds of
encodings encodings where there are many
prime
prime factors and uh different things in
code with respect to different prime
factors
okay so that was our warm-up now let's
take
the next step the next step is k equals
two
right so now we have one multiplication
that you're allowed to do
and um what will change here is that
we'll still have our one special prime
factor c
but now we're gonna have two
distinguished prime factors a1 and a2
right so we'll add the a2 representation
here
okay i again give random generators for
each of the prime subgroups except for c
so those are these two here and now
our h's change so the h's have
something random in the c group but h1
is missing an a1 component and h2 is
missing an
a2 component okay that's the idea
of these h's and now what we assume is
that it's hard for the adversary to
distinguish between a level one encoding
of again a completely random element or
an element that is zero in the c
subgroup
okay so let's step back for a moment and
just think about this
you know why does this make sense and
what are we really
assuming here like what is the essence
of this assumption with regard to the
multilinear map
so it's usually good to think about what
are the limits right you know what could
we
wiggle here and then break the
assumption
so one thing to note is that i
definitely can't give
a generator for the c sub group right
the generator for the signature would
look like this
r 0 0 then what i could do is just
multiply
the t element with gc and then zero test
right in this case i would get a
non-zero
outcome but in this case i would get a
zero outcome right
so this would be one way of breaking so
it's very important that i'm not giving
that
out right that's one thing to think
about the other thing is that
we're very much relying on the fact that
there is a bound of two
right that the max level here is two
if the max level was 3 then again the
assumption would be false
right because then what i could do is
multiply t by
both h1 and h2 which would eliminate
the a1 and the a2 component and
therefore again
yield zero in this case and non-zero in
this case right
so entity that's why we're going to
eventually call this the elimination
assumption because
we have these elimination elements which
allow you to eliminate
but we set our max multi-linearity at
just the right level so that you
shouldn't be able to test
okay and i want to stress that this is
also something that we've seen many
times in cryptography so
for example the bilinear assumptions
that we typically use
if we could have a tri-linear version of
that map
most of them would would break right the
d-lin and
uh the bddh assumption all these things
would break if we just had
if we could just go from two to three
right so here too we want to
expl you know very critically use the
fact that we're putting a specific bound
of k here
okay all right and then the actual
assumption that we're going to make is
just the
k analog of this okay with one little
little additional thing
so you know now we go to k a general k
it'll be the k
multi-linear sub-group elimination
assumption and
we'll have again one special prime
factor c k
distinguished prime factors now a1
through ak and then there'll be some
polynomial many other primes i'm not
going to really talk about them they're
not going to play
really any role in the assumption but we
need them for some technical reasons
again we have our crt representation we
always start with c and then the
distinguished primes
okay he gets the adversary gets
generators of every prime sub group
except for c
and then these h i's are these
eliminators right
so again they're random everywhere
except exactly
at the ai component so h i is zero in
the ai component
right and again it's hard for the
adversary to distinguish between
something that's completely random in
all the
distinguished and special primes or one
that is random in the distinguished
primes but not the special prime
okay and this is the assumption that we
want to make
and indeed as far as we know there are
no attacks on this assumption using the
latest and greatest multilinear maps
that we're going to hear about
after the break so all right
this is our assumption and now we want
to
leverage this assumption to actually
build
indistinguishability obfuscation before
i do that i want to stress
right now look at this assumption right
there are no matrices here you know
there are no programs here
so you know we'll need to do some work
right we need to somehow
take an assumption that doesn't have
anything obfuscation like in it and we
want to somehow reduce it which is what
we always do as cryptographers right
all right good so how are we going to do
that what's the plan what's the game
plan here how are we going to argue
uh security for obfuscation so
we need to prove indistinguishability
right we need to start with
an obfuscation of c0 and move eventually
to the obfuscation of c1
these are equivalent programs meaning
they have identical input optic behavior
but still how are we going to do this
how are we going to start with these
encoded matrices and somehow wind up
with these completely different
encodered matrices
right c0 and c1 in matrix form
every single matrix could be different
right so what's the idea here
well we're going to give a hybrid
argument what we always do in crypto
right and since we're giving a hybrid
argument
inevitably we're going to have to
somehow slowly switch out some part of
the c0 computation
and switch in some part of the c1
computation right that's just inevitable
we have to do that
since we're starting with c0 and we're
ending with c1 okay
the question is how do we do it so
the key idea here is to use the one
thing that we have in our hand which is
killian simulation right we've already
seen
that when you're restricted to the
matrices that are
needed just for a single input in that
case
information theoretically the matrices
that correspond to c0
are identically distributed to the
matrices that correspond to c1
right so that allows us to information
theoretically move between c0 and c1
but only for a single input so then
the main you know work that we have to
do here
is to somehow go over every single input
and transfer it from c0
and move it to c1 okay so the way we'll
do that is by actually having
two to the n hybrids in our in our in
our hybrid argument
where again n is the input size this may
seem
a little bit worrisome to see a two to
the n in the high number of hybrids but
again
this is okay by complexity leveraging
something that we've seen many many
times
so if we assume something is
sub-exponentially hard
then by choosing the security parameter
in such a way that
you know the security parameter to this
epsilon is greater than n
then we can have enough hardness so that
we can actually go through two to the
n-hybrid arguments and still have
sub-exponential hardness left over in
the end so in fact we'll assume
sub-exponentially secure multi-linear
subgroup decision
elimination assumption and we'll end up
with sub-exponentially secure
indistinguishability obfuscation okay
all right so let's zoom in a little bit
more on this strategy
that we're building here the idea is
again to isolate each input right so
that we can apply killian
so how will we do that we'll do that by
having
polynomially many parallel obfuscations
okay where each of these parallel
obfuscations is responsible for a
different
bucket of inputs
and how will this work
well we'll have two types of hybrid
steps
in hybrid type 1 all we're doing
is reallocating inputs between
two obfuscations of c0 so i have one
bucket for c0 another bucket for the
same program c0
and i'm just moving some inputs from
here into this bucket
okay this is actually the place where
we'll use our assumption
okay the second
type of hybrid arises when we have
managed
to get just a single input isolated in
this bucket
right then this parallel obfuscation
will only have those matrices right that
correspond to a single input
and we'll be able to apply killian and
switch over to c1
information theoretically okay and
we'll keep doing this until eventually
we've moved everything over into the c1
bucket
okay all right
excuse me
um so you can see here that this is this
is basically information theoretic right
so all of the
work is happening in hybrid uh type one
right let's think about a different way
of thinking about hybrid type one
what we're basically asking is the
following
suppose that i had some code that looked
like this sort of
strange looking code what does it do it
checks if the input is less than or
equal to 37
if so it runs c0 of x then it checks if
the input is either 38 or 39
and it runs c0 of x this is the same
thing but just does it in two different
places
right otherwise it runs c1 of x okay
hybrid type 1 is basically like taking
this code
and just modifying this from 37 to 38.
i'm just reallocating the input 38
from this branch to this branch where
both branches do identical stuff
right the code is actually identical
this seems like such a minor change
right and yet sort of the key lesson of
this is that
the ability to make just this very minor
change is actually sufficient
if we can do this we can go all the way
to obfuscating arbitrary programs
matrix branching programs that are
equivalent to each other
okay all right
so um let me uh
zoom in a little bit more on what's
going on here so suppose we start
with some obfuscation normal obfuscation
like the one that we saw
um in the in the beginning we'll just
create sort of a parallel copy of the
sophistication
and now sort of the key step will be to
sort of bifurcate the input so what i
mean by that is
we'll zero out the one matrix here and
the zero matrix here
right and if we zeroed out this matrix
and zero dot this matrix
then we split up the inputs right one
half of the inputs go here
one half of the inputs are covered by
this right
and this is again the key part the key
part we're going to make use of the
assumption
then we can keep doing this right we can
pick another place keep doing it
and eventually if we keep doing this
we'll eventually
isolate a single input right and as i
said before
now we can apply killian we need to be
sure
though that this parallel obfuscation is
using r matrices that are completely
independent
of all the other r matrices in order to
be able to apply killian but that's what
we'll do
okay and we switch over to c1 and now
we finally got our first input that's
actually handled by c1
and all the rest are handled by c0 right
but we've gotten started
right and now we can isolate the next
input move that to c1
then we could merge the two c1s together
in the same way that we
bifurcated the uh the c zeros here
right and in this way eventually we'll
wind up
with uh everything just in the hand of
c1
and that is an obfuscation of c1 right
that'll complete the hybrid
so again the key yes
yeah i mean actually replace with the
all zeros matrix
right so this matrix in other words if i
try to evaluate this
if i ever have an input that starts with
zero then i'll end up with just a matrix
of all zeros
in this component in this parallel
obfuscation
so i literally mean zeroing out that
computation
yes the new objective program is all of
these
things together all of these things
together yeah and i haven't told you
exactly how to do that but i'll tell you
that in just a minute
yes so what we're assuming here is that
c0 and c1 are both
branching programs oblivious they all
have exactly the same size
and all that
yes exactly they all go you know blue
blue red green blue red green for the
blue input bit the red input bit and the
green a bit
it's easy to do that this is just an
obliviousness thing you can just
pad with identity matrices so it's not
an assumption
but it is critical we do need that
all right so um very good so this will
eventually
uh complete this yes
um i'm not sure what you mean the hybrid
argument can replace it with nested
hybrids so it's a new technique
so you can go from tourist to n to two
to the log n
it's a new technique oh okay okay
you're saying is there a way that we
could i i don't see how to make that
work
um but i'd be happy to talk with you
offline about it yeah
so all right
um very good so again the the key thing
right to make this work
is exactly the zeroing out of a matrix
right
what we need to do is you know if i have
these two parallel obfuscations i need
to be able to sort of
look at this one matrix in the eye and
just zero them out
right and i needed that to be
indistinguishable to the adversary
right so that's like the elementary
operation that i need to be able to do
and that's where i'm going to be using
my assumption right so let's think about
that
what could we use in our assumption to
zero out something
actually it's right here right that's
exactly the way we've made the
assumption
it allows us to go in the special prime
factor
from something random to something that
is zero right
so this means that what we'll do is
we'll think of these parallel
obfuscations as happening with respect
to
different primes right a1 c
and so on and so forth and i'll assign c
to this one
and let's say a1 to this one okay
and now if i use t right that i get from
the assumption
to create these two encodings
i'm done right because if t came from
the first distribution
then both of these matrices will exist
but if it came from the second
distribution
then this would be zeroed out right so
that is the essential step
that we need to do here okay now i also
need to make all of these other matrices
um that's the part that i won't go into
too much depth on
but the essential idea here is that i
need to use the h
i's for i not equal to 1
to make the rest of these now why it's
because i need that in both cases
right no matter what t is i need all the
other matrices to exist
so they better always be non-zero
with respect to c and with respect to a1
and that is the case
for all of these his for i not equal to
one that's the way we that's the way
they were they were made
right okay now
there's still that issue of the input
mixing attack right
again i'm not going to give you the
details but the essence of it
are these missing points in these his
right these his were random everywhere
except at one low point where they were
zero
that is the idea that is the key feature
we use
to be able to enforce input consistency
so the fact that there's a missing
thing there is actually used exactly to
force
good behavior on the part of the on the
part of the yes
um actually no the number of primes is
the number of parallel obfuscations
right so that actually has to do
with um it's going to be something
that's a polynomial in n in fact it'll
be a linear n
so that has to do with how many cases do
i need
to subdivide before i've isolated an
input
so that i can do this traversal right i
need to traverse my way
through this tree to go from all c0 to
all c1
right it will it will not be related to
the length of the of the branchiogram
itself it'll be related only to the
input size
right the input size is fixed but
whatever that is
it'll be linear in that
one
no no no again it'll be the number of
input bits
right so if the input length is n
then i'll need something like 2n prime
something like that
3m yeah
it turns out that read one's branching
programs are really uninteresting uh to
obfuscate
um but you don't have the yes
exactly these kind of things get sort of
solved for free in situations like that
again it trivializes in that case
because there's sort of nothing nothing
to be done
um but for obfuscating them that depends
on exactly how we define
uh the notion of a of a matrix branching
program i
skipped that part here if you use the
barrington definition then there's
really nothing that can be done
if use a different definition then
actually we need to do some additional
randomization to make this work which i
haven't talked about
and in that case it does become
non-trivial
yes how do you evaluate this parallel
observation don't you have to sort of
know which column you're right right no
so that's the nice thing the point is
that
we just each of these of parallel
obfuscations is just in different primes
right so when i evaluate one obfuscation
i'm actually automatically in parallel
evaluating all of the obfuscations and
if
all of them are zero then i'll zero test
right
and if any one of them is non-zero then
it'll look like it's non-zero right
so when i zero out something i'm just
putting it taking it out of
consideration
right it's not going to affect the
outcome okay
all right so um so that's the
the the rough idea of how how this works
and how we're able to reduce
obfuscation to a concrete natural
assumption that you know
that that that doesn't have obfuscation
within it and i just want to stress that
point again
you know the reduction that we're
talking that we're describing here
the programs are all fixed right the
reduction knows
every single matrix here that's involved
we don't need to hide that from the
reduction at all
if you think about it in that like if
then thing that i showed you
the two cases right that are known to
the reduction p0 and p1
they tell you what the programs are it's
only the inputs that get moved around
right so that's really critical and it
allows the reduction just to directly
build all these matrices
it doesn't need to take them from the
assumption or anything like that they
just you can just build them himself
okay all right so um
with that's a sort of my yes
how many um sets of matrices does the
program is
the problem gonna happen
so you mean like how many how many
parallel ones yeah that's what
kotec was asking it's gonna be something
like um
some some linear something linear in n
something like 2 3n
universe you cannot actually evaluate it
i mean you evaluate it but you get
something encoded
and even though it has zero you can
attach
so what you're testing for is that all
of the parallel
evaluations evaluate to zero
right if they all evaluate to zero then
when you do all these iterated matrix
products you'll get
a matrix which will have one element
that'll be zero everywhere
right and then you can zero test for it
and that's fine and remember it's
critical that c0 and c1 are functionally
equivalent
right that means that their output is
always going to be identical no matter
what on any input
and that's very important here zero this
matrix obviously
you see the you know you you put the
subset in the first input to b1 x0 x1 to
v1
no no no hold on remember the input
selects all of the parallel obfuscations
at once right
so if you selected this matrix you're
automatically selecting this matrix
this matrix you know all that right
if i know that this is the assumption
that you're going to use to zero out the
right matrix i'll select
x one equals to one and then it will see
that
this is zero this is non-zero so i mean
no because it'll be blinded by this guy
right here m1 exists so if you try to
just take this
part you're also taking this part and
when you evaluate it
it's not n programs it's all one program
that are just combined using crt
using chinese remainder theorem yes
that's what i meant by
here we're using the chinese remainder
theorem to you know inextricably you
know yeah
link all these things together yeah
it's almost like an or it's kind of you
know it favors
zero versus non versus non-zero but what
what is the guarantee that we need
we need that if all the programs agree
on the output
then the output is correct if they don't
agree then
we don't care because that'll never
arise in our hybrids right our hybrids
only ever apply
to functional equivalent programs
yeah they all agree on yes
they all agree on one output or they're
zero
in which case they're just out of
consideration right their their output
does not affect
whether the final output is going to be
zero or non-zero does that answer your
question
kind of okay so you have these hybrids
and then you want to go to c1 right so
the last hybrid within c0
you want it to be a single input single
algorithm right
yes yes
yeah so the last hybrid you'll have will
look like this
so you're exactly right that will have
with respect to c1 we'll have a bunch of
programs right that cover kind of
everything except
for with respect to c0 we'll just have
the last
input maybe it'll look like this just
for simplicity
right all these are 0.
right so remember that these are
functional equivalent
so if i evaluate it at the let's say 0
to the n
input right then i will get the same
output here as i will get here
right so if the final output is zero
then it'll be zero in both places and if
it's non-zero there will be nonzero in
both places
on the other hand if i evaluate it on
some other input let's say one to the n
then this part just doesn't contribute
it'll just be whatever c1 does
that's the idea
all right yes is it correct to think
about it as evaluating over the product
like this is between like crt
representation exactly yeah yeah
we're evaluating because each individual
encoding has components from all the
different parallel obfuscations
when you finally evaluate it you end up
with something that has a crt
representation
of the output in every with respect to
each prime
right and they all have to be zero for
it to be zero testing to zero
yes the zero test at the end
checks if it's zero in all the in all of
the places exactly it's not even zero
and one
i it's like the answer is not zero
exactly if it's not even if it's not
if it's not it if it's not zero and even
one then the answer is interpreted as
non-zero
it's yes it's it's like yes it is like
or but it's
it's it's just slightly different
because one is being used to select an
input and one is
an actual or you know
yes it seems like all of these n primes
you said two n or three n prizes
i just need a little bit of room because
i need to be able to um
uh do this just sort of do this dance of
moving things around
two n is probably overkill maybe we need
n plus three or something like that but
yeah
we just need to be able to have enough
room to do the stance
yes so so um
a the product of all the crimes is known
also to the i'm sorry
yes uh the composite number n
um it could be known or it could not be
known it's actually not needed here
it's not needed here so that that will
go into the actual destruction
exactly yeah we don't need it to be no
there's no assumption here
there's no factoring assumption here
okay all right so that's uh that's that
um yes unknown is it obviously insecure
or not so
if the individual primes are known yeah
then banner's hopeless
so the assumption seems to be that uh we
could always throw out a special prize
right but like so we're zeroing out
among all of
within this single hybrid we're stirring
right the critical point here is that
you actually cannot well yeah
okay sorry um
do you see what's going on here so we
cannot um
you you should not be able to zero out
all of these but not the special one
that would allow you to distinguish
which is exactly what we have
okay yes so in your picture when you're
zeroing out to the first pit
the matrix corresponding first but are
you actually zeroing out all of those
matrices corresponding to the first but
at the same time
i don't i don't need to but but i'm i
was hiding that we will actually have
some different hybrids we'll zero them
out one by one
but then doesn't have to be proportional
to the length of the program at that
point as opposed to
the length of the input okay
k is always proportional to the length
of the program k is the level of
multilinearity
that was always the case sorry the
number of primes is different
that's n the number of primes with
respect to respect to the
the length of the input okay
okay okay yes
i don't know how to do that let me let
me just
i'll just draw another quick picture to
illustrate what we need
so think of it as a binary tree
it's kind of like a pebbling problem
so what i the basic step allows me to
take a pebble that i have here
and cross it out and get two pebbles
here
right and what i need to do is i need to
reach
the leaf right
so when i reach these leaves i have all
these pebbles which is like n
bevels right and then i can switch this
to
from c0 to c1 i can switch this from c0
to c1
and then i can bring the back up right i
can combine the two pebbles and get
a c1 pebble here right and then i can
see what i'm saying so for that reason i
i seem to need
n primes
the root node yeah so the root node
corresponds to all inputs all 2 to the n
inputs
all right we will actually have a
discussion
phase after the next talk so maybe i'll
take the rest of the questions then i'm
going to talk briefly
uh stealing a few minutes of your break
i'm sorry about that
um about where we are where we're where
we
as opposed to where we want to be with
respect to obfuscation there's a huge
amount of work to be done here
right so first of all you know we
have this assumption over a candidate
map
so what is that candidate map you'll
find out in the next lecture so eric and
mandy will talk
talk to us about that and why does it
why does this
assumption you know seem to be secure
despite recent attacks there are ways
that we can defend against them
okay once we've done this
we can bootstrap i already mentioned
that and then
this afternoon brent will tell us about
how to bootstrap to turing machines
and then there's some breaking news uh
justin will tell us
how to go to ram programs uh in the
breaking news session
and we can even achieve constant
multiplicative size overhead
in the in the in the obfuscation so the
size of the obfuscation
can in fact just be a factor two bigger
than the original
unobfuscated program plus some
significant additive factors but let's
put those aside
um and fermenting will tell us about
that this afternoon
um but again these are new assumptions
right and new m maps which is you know
unexplored space so what can we do about
that
so there are a few ways forward right
now with regard to multilinear maps
we're in this sort of attack defend
cycle right we want to
come up with new math we want to then
attack it and then
you know build it back up which uh
probably doesn't leave all of us very
satisfied but it's been a very
successful
way of doing crypto for the last several
decades in the sense of
block ciphers with the aes competition
even by linear assumptions over
specific elliptic curve families you
know specific elliptic curve families
were
attacked over time and and all that
that's where we are right now it'd be
great if we could get out of that
um it would be wonderful if we could for
example reduce the multilinear subgroup
elimination assumption
to some nicer assumption by building a
new candidate
mmap scheme with the goal of targeting
this particular assumption right that
would be great i don't know how to do
that
and of course we could also explore
entirely new ways to build i o
right which could potentially give us
other assumptions that we could use
and there's some really exciting partial
progress towards this
so um a new paper by ananth and jain
and bhitansky and veganaton uh the two
papers i should say
so you'll hear about this on wednesday
afternoon abhishek will present it
and what they do is they show how to
build and distinguishability obfuscation
from another primitive
called compact functional encryption
unfortunately currently we only know how
to build this
primitive using i o so so far we haven't
made progress but there's hope
right potentially this other primitive
compact functional encryption maybe we
could build it without using i o
which would give us another route to i o
which would be great
right
so essentially compact functional
encryption is another name for you
i mean i don't know no no no no no no
they are very
they're different in flavor and you
you'll hear about this on on wednesday
in more detail
but uh no but they're very different
they're very different parameters this
is a non-trivial proof
to show how to go from compact deffi to
io
the other direction is also non-trivial
uh to go from io
uh to compact fe so um
and in fact there are many fe schemes
that don't have the compactness
properties even using i o
so there's really a lot um to explore
here
okay and then finally um i want to leave
you all with something a little bit more
um adventurous which uh
some of you who have already seen so
um you know cryptography is all about
hardness
right no not exactly we also have
information threaded cryptography which
i know and i love
we all know and love it um but let's put
that aside for the moment but
essentially cryptograph
cryptography is about leveraging
hardness right
and if we think about the evolution of
our field it's remarkable
how it's proceeded right we started with
these sort of basic assumptions about
rsa
ddh and factoring and we built these
beautiful
objects right this uh public encryption
multi-party computation
zero knowledge signatures in fact it's
so
really beautiful that if this is all
there was to crypto
we should all be happy right it's so so
beautiful right
we could spend our entire lives just
watering this one uh little
uh little little little part of the of
of of our hardness landscape
right but that's not what happened right
in the early 2000s
these new sources of hardness came these
bilinear assumptions
and out of those grew identity-based
encryption
attribute-based encryption short
signatures beautiful wonderful stuff
right and then there were
there was gentry's uh ideal coset
problem in lwe
right another new source of hardness out
of which we got this amazing object of
functional
fully homomorphic encryption and many
other things right
and now finally we have this new source
of hardness
of multi-linear map candidates and we
have this amazing stuff coming out of it
obfuscation
[ __ ] wear and lots and lots of stuff
you'll that you'll hear
more about later in the in the workshop
right you know what about all this
other space right we've only really kind
of begun
to explore the sources of hardness that
are actually present out there
i think and uh i think we should all
really think about that right the sort
of the evolution of our field has been
with
new sources of hardness and we should
think about how to leverage that
so just to conclude obfuscation i think
i'm really excited about it as you
probably guessed um
but it's still in its infancy right we
really need a huge amount of work here
and i think that we have to be willing
to take risks i think that we should be
you know that's another sort of lesson
from the previous slide is that
taking risks have really paid off right
for our field and we should continue to
do so
i didn't talk about it much but
efficiency is a major major baldness
this is the anti-theme you know
anti-efficiency theme
in this workshop so we have polynomial
time we even have constant
size overhead but the computational
overhead is
huge it's polynomial but the constants
you know
easily exceed 2 to the 100 you know
small
numbers like 2 to 100 that's probably
something we should address
and you know finally
you'll learn a lot more throughout the
rest of the workshop so thank you